can you tell us a little bit about your
journey Jason when I found out I was a
finalist I basically felt I'd won
because I never
to be chosen as a finalist the
application itself is really
straightforward so that's one thing that
I was worried about it first you know I
think we all worry about before we
actually look at how to apply for
something like this you think oh god
it's gonna be so much work and so
difficult to understand it was more just
about finding my own voice the Elton's
itself was you mentioned it's a
competition but also you said a
celebration and I guess I was a little
bit more focused on the competition side
and that was making me anxious but the
celebration side is definitely a big
part of it and it was really exciting to
attend the ceremony and to feel that
sense of celebration of everyone's work
I would say apply first of all so do it
apply there's no reason I can think of
if you've got some material for learners
or for teachers if your English language
teacher that that's been working for you
that you're excited about I think the
more experience you have getting it out
there getting it in front of people you
might be a little bit intimidated by at
first but I think this will just help
you become a better teacher and meet
more people and connect more in the
field of yield sandwiches which is so
vital for for your future for our
futures talk to talk to your students
talk to your colleagues a little bit
about you know what do they like about
material what do they like about you
because you got some of their voices to
help you because I think where I was
struggling I was really just going from
my head even though I had heard feedback
from people so when I stopped the
application and then sort of asked
people again and they've got more ideas
it helped me talk about it because I
think sometimes we get bogged down you
know on ourselves and then I started to
get insecure so yeah talking to other
people about it is good if anyone wants
to direct encouragement for me contact
me and I'll try to well on my website
you can email me there's a contact so
fluency MC calm and there's a contact
goes right to me but I'm very active on
on Facebook so if you message me there
as well and also the innovative teachers
of English group on Facebook we have
almost a quarter of a million people now
definitely the biggest most active group
of English teachers in the world right
now thanks oh that's a great place also